alright guys so picture this you're 18
years old and you're really good at csgo
so good you can go pro so good a major
team offers you a contract but then it
happens
you find out that there's a vac banned
account associated with your name and
all of a sudden no more contract no more
pro career no more csgo so what do you
do well after exhausting all of their
options you sue that
[Music]
alright guys before we get into the
video proper I got one question for you
if you haven't subscribed to the channel
already what are you waiting for let's
get to 2 million subscribers by the end
of the year and on a serious note it
does help us continue to produce content
just like this so go ahead keep me
reading lawsuits all night
I don't mind now you guys know what a
vac ban is it is a permanent
non-negotiable valve anti-cheat system
ban that generally speaking is a death
sentence for top tier pro careers from
cali to forsaken many a legendary
cheater has been deleted from pro play
thanks to a vac ban but what if the vac
banned account associated with you
wasn't you at all what if you never
cheated what if this entire thing was
all a misunderstanding
that stemmed from a LAN party you had
when you were 14 years old
well that's allegedly what's happening
to Yampa a young csgo player who's suing
valve for an unfair unreasonable vac ban
and we have the lawsuit now if you guys
haven't heard of you before he's a young
finnish csgo player who's currently
listed as inactive for an or called SJ
gaming he's suing valve to have his back
ban removed and for about two hundred
and ninety three thousand dollars in
damages and legal fees the lawsuit
alleges that yam p lost money lost
business opportunities in his profession
and basically had his career severely
cut short
hence the monetary damages after all
guys with a vac ban you can't play in a
major and if you can't play in a major
you're just not a valuable commodity in
csgo this by the way is the vac banned
account now there's not a lot of
information on it but just look at some
of the past names mad hacker leet mad
cos bad why you bad
get rekt get rekt mate suka blat blat
suka mean come on that's not a cheater
account I don't know what is now I know
what you're saying call him
why should a young Pro with a vac banned
account even be given a second chance
what right does he have to sue valve
well according to yam P it all started
back in 2015 when he was 14 years old a
young yam P and his buddies were having
a
and party at yam peas house now not
everybody on csgo so he took his parents
credit card with permission I assume
bought a bunch of copies and started
handing them out now at least one of
those friends pays him back that night
for the game thus in some way
transferring ownership of that account
from yam pea to his buddy no remember
that because that's gonna be important
later now eventually this buddies
account the one that yam P originally
bought for him and that he payed for
allegedly gets a vac ban now we don't
know exactly why or exactly what this
guy did with his account but according
to a letter that's entered into evidence
in this lawsuit the guy installed cheats
in order to beat another friend at a 1v1
game now remember this account was
created by yam P so it's still
associated with his identity flash
forward to 2019 and yam P is given his
big first contract with og eSports I
mean look this was a rare opportunity
for yam he's a young csgo player at the
start of his career and in comes this
big legacy organization like og wanna
put their first foot in csgo and they're
offering big money for it
you gotta believe this was a dream come
true for the guy only problem was that
the contractual negotiations fell apart
when the team learned that yappi was
associated with a vac banned account now
according to the lawsuit when yam P
found out there was a vac banned account
associated with his name apparently he
didn't know up until now he contacted
valve believe it or not they exchanged
emails stories were told proof was
offered but valve would not budge and
the young finn remain banned valves
responses were short simple and brutally
clear like this one hi Elias we received
a question below about your eligibility
to play in majors our investigation has
found a vac banned account that we've
concluded was under your control at the
time of the band therefore you are not
eligible to participate at our events
best of luck to you but yeah he kept
trying he lawyered up and at one point
even invoked the European data
protection regulation but valve still
wouldn't budge his team SJ gaming also
reached out and so did the
counter-strike Players Association but
neither had any more luck than yam pian
self and so here we are sitting at a
forty page lawsuit so what's filling the
forty pages well aside from telling his
story and offering proof for the whole
2015 LAN party thing the MP also invokes
the Finnish Consumer Protection Act
which among other things states the
following if a term in a contract
referred to in the act is unreasonable
for the point of view of the consumer or
if an unreasonable result would ensue
from its application the term may be
adjusted or it may be disregarded
basically what yam pees lawsuit is
arguing is that when he was 14 years old
and he bought those counter strike
accounts he was a consumer buying a
product and having his entire pro career
limited so severely by a vac ban on
account that he allegedly denieth in
control is unreasonable and therefore
should be disregarded the lawsuit also
emphasizes that as a child a 14-year old
cannot quote take into account the
impact of a lifelong ban other
prohibition or punishment in their
future life and they also say that the
Steam User Agreement doesn't say
anything about not attending majors even
if you have a vac ban now from Valve's
point of view there is a section on the
steam website under frequently asked
questions that does seem to address this
sort of thing it's under the header I
was not using my account when it was vac
banned can the ban be removed and the
answer is quote no regardless of who was
using the account at the time of the
infraction vac bans are permanent and
will not be removed while we understand
this can be frustrating we must maintain
a zero-tolerance policy for cheating to
foster a fair game that all players will
enjoy and from the emails that are
offered into evidence for this lawsuit
it doesn't seem like gaben & Co are
changing their minds on this any time
soon
I read you one email from valve earlier
and there are several others but they
all basically say the same thing they're
short curt to the point and the gist of
it is sorry kid best of luck now at the
risk of editorializing a little bit this
all just seems kind of unfair doesn't it
I mean if we believe the story about yam
P not being involved with the back ban
at all and at this point it is still
alleged then it seems like
that we're never gonna see this guy play
csgo at the highest level he's obviously
a player with some merit or else oh gee
wouldn't be so eager to have signed him
at this point we're never gonna see what
he can really do at a top level and it
seems like he might not have done
anything wrong to deserve that
there are several letters entered into
evidence in this lawsuit that seemed to
be written by yam P himself and in them
he comes off really honest and really
sincere
guys this kid just wants to play CS he
wants to live the eSports dream and he's
willing to suffer an investigation to
prove what he's saying is true if valve
can just step up do their part and clear
his name then he can get on with doing
what he loves to do and we can watch him
do it alright guys I got the emails I
got the comments I got the Twitter DM I
know you're all very upset that my Game
of Thrones books are out of order so
let's just fix that live now okay so
what what goes first
a game of Thrones is the first book
right it's definitely the first book
right Game of Thrones okay what's next
Clash of Kings it's definitely Clash of
Kings right yeah definitely Storm of
Swords then it's got to be a feast of
crows and then a Dance with Dragons
right